so the dust still hasn't settled in
Russia it's hard to know what's going on
but President Biden held a press
conference to ensure the public that the
U.S was absolutely not involved watch
we gave Putin no excuse to blame this on
the west or to blame this on NATO
we made clear that we were not involved
we had nothing to do with it this was
part of a struggle within the Russian
system
Michael Walters a congressman from
Florida and he joins us now he also used
to be a Green Beret Commander
um Congressman break it down for us look
I don't want to put any of our operators
at risk can you explain to our audience
what went down
overseas
foreign
yeah well look you have a basically an
independent militia mercenary group that
was more powerful and more effective
than the Russian army that was causing
all kinds of friction uh internally they
were effective they've been effective in
Africa and the Middle East and they were
the most effective force in uh in
Ukraine by far the Russian army was
looking to turn on this group because
they don't suffer competitors uh very
well and it appears that Putin is trying
to play Both Sides to his Advantage
right and that's what strong men do they
appear strong and they appear to be
pulling the strings what I think pulled
the rug out from under Putin himself was
that he didn't have the forces to stop
this militia group that the Wagner group
as they turned uh you know the snake
turned to bite the hand
Wagner shot down seven Russian aircraft
as they were marching on as they were
marching on Moscow and I'll remind
everyone 85 percent of the Russian
military is now completely committed to
Ukraine the other 15 percent spread all
over all the way out to the Pacific uh
so this there's some real cracks now in
Putin's uh dictatorship why does this
matter to us why does this matter to you
know to the everyday American I'm number
one Russian nukes and I'm glad to see
Biden's staff yet again walking back his
irresponsible statements about regime
change we need stability in Russia on
those nukes but we also this is a good
thing in the sense that Russia is weaker
it's weaker in Ukraine and this
mercenary Special Forces Group can't go
control minds for example in Africa of
the critical minerals that we need for
our Congressman right forgive me for
interrupting you but where is he where
is he yeah where I mean this is he was
Powers with Putin and the Russians are
are very good at disinformation so where
is this guy and Putin doesn't let
anybody live I mean he's killed their
own family members so where is this guy
so this is what's so unclear is he going
to use this Uprising as uh as an excuse
to create scapegoats in his Minister of
Defense uh and in his generals for all
of their failures uh because uh pagosian
was a bit of a Robin Hood figure he was
seen as the only one speaking for the
average Russian soldier who didn't have
the equipment and ammo that they needed
and being fed into a meat grinder so
does he you does Putin use that to his
advantage or is he simply buying time to
defuse the situation and percussion is
going to die in his sleep that part is
incredibly uh unclear at this point he
was also more ruthless than Putin as
well I mean this is a guy that wanted to
take Kiev whereas Putin was like look
there's a lot of Russian history there
as well so I know for the average Day
American or someone that's following
this they say no one can be worse than
Putin but this guy was
no you're absolutely right and I've told
people that are calling for regime
change I mean Biden famously said it
while in in Poland one we have to have
stability on those nukes and two be
careful what you wish for you could get
far worse it is much more likely that
someone uh even more hardcore even more
hardened and dictatorial than Putin to
replace him not some enlightened
Centrist moderate Democratic figure uh
and and that is uh certainly not good
for U.S interests that's exactly right
we'll be following it Congressman thanks
so much for joining the program
all right thank you hey Sean Hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to Fox
News YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else